it's never gonna work you can't make a
potato camera potatoes are meant for one
thing only eating
[Music]
red check out this picture i just took
it's one of my favorites did you take
that on potato or something actually i
did
so there's a saying on the internet when
you see a really bad picture you go
what'd you take that on your potato well
i wanted to answer that question yes i
did i've never actually tried to make a
camera before it sounds really
complicated but the thing is if i use
film it makes my life a little bit
easier so here's the challenge take an
actual potato carve it out so that you
have a film spot inside where your film
can sit and you slap a lens on the front
can i actually make a working potato
camera let's find out
there's a whole range of tests that we
have to do here i think at the end of
the day what's probably gonna happen
we're gonna build the camera we're going
to keep it in a bag or a box until it's
time to take a picture at which point
let's take it out expose it put it back
keep it quick we also got lots of
problems we're gonna have to deal with
one
light if any light gets into this potato
when it has film in it it's going to
ruin the film it's going to expose it we
need to cut one of these open and see if
light can travel through a potato i'm
thinking it can yep
that's a lot of light
how do you want to deal with this i kind
of don't want to spray paint it black i
don't think it'll adhere or dry i agree
you know it might work build a little 3d
printed chamber and just keep this end
open
how long would that take to print i
think probably do it quick let's try it
let's do it time to do some 3d modeling
combining new technology with old
potatoes and pla printers
and they have a chamber for the film
ideally two it would be ideal to like
something like this film backing 38
millimeters tall yeah so 50 millimeters
wide so this guy's actually record a
little couple lines here and there okay
test test test test test
you guys ready to get
smoked there we go that's it if you just
cover the top with gaff tape it's gonna
be a little big we'll see what happens
if you do let's go smaller i'd rather go
smaller than too big i don't know
those things are hard because it's like
how big is it it's like 40 40
millimeters tall the film's 36 it
doesn't give us much play nick i'm a
daring man we're gonna take some risks
here we go
[Music]
then we get into the mechanics of this
thing where the lens is going to sit
i'll chop that flat and we'll kind of
carve out a little bit of a hole that'll
the lens will fit in we're going to take
the top of the potato and chop that like
this it's going to lift the top off
carve out a spot inside now the thing is
we need to be able to roll the film
through here we'll have a film gate and
then it'll go down here into the chamber
where the film can go so we called
around town here in la you think you'd
be able to find a place that can do
whatever you want for film but no film's
dead apparently so the best we can find
was a shop that would do nine inch
strips of film so we bought a couple 35
millimeter film rolls we're going to
have to do nine inch strips at a time
now it's kind of a waste we only do one
picture for nine inch strips so nick and
i are challenging ourselves to make it
so you can do multiple exposures on one
strip of film rolling the film through
the film gate how do we know if we can
fit the film in there simple how big is
film 24 by 36 million see how wide this
tape is oh it's perfect this is like
exactly the same size
wow who would have thought they would
have standardized tape rolls and film
the same size all right so we need nine
inches
vegan camera imagine that there's a hole
cut in this balsa wood and here's our
film roll we're gonna go in the back
open it up move the film one one frame
forwards theoretically this should all
work out a-okay look at that it's in
focus
yeah
yeah
the little proof of concept build seems
to be working when i was some real test
to do here
what's up peter how's it going
good to be back finally it's been too
long went through my second year in
college in san francisco it was a great
year got to live with my best friends
lots of adventures great times but i
also shot my very own spider-man short
film which i will now be editing
here which is pretty exciting so
basically i've been wanting to make a
spider-man movie for as long as i can
remember i grew up watching the sam
raimi spider-man movies probably my
biggest inspirations so good don't watch
spider-man 3.
one of my pet peeves is just bringing
that money up i hate that movie so much
it's definitely its own movie i wrote a
script for spider-man short last year
and i've been working on getting it made
thankfully i had put together a teaser
that is already on my instagram showed
that to jake had some of the effects in
it he was impressed he showed it to sam
and nico they were into it and so they
gave me the budget to make this short
film all on my own in san francisco
there were two big challenges with this
project one it's a period piece it's set
in the 1960s which for a short film is
very difficult because costuming takes a
lot of money you know it's really hard
to get that many extras to fill a
background to make you know the space
feel realistic part of how we're going
to fix that is through lots and lots of
visual effects like
so many the other challenge was putting
spider-man in a movie because obviously
that comes with a lot of challenges uh
you know acrobatics the costume took
many many hours to create made it from
scratch couldn't get a stunt double so
thankfully we have visual effects right
now i'm working on creating spider-man
from the ground up in cgi a lot of it's
going to be hand animating which is
really tough mostly the swinging
sequences because you can't really film
someone swinging in between buildings to
like see how their movements look
hopefully i can finish this before the
end of june which is when it's due
so i guess we'll see yeah it's going to
be tough i'm going to be working some
late hours probably definitely lots of
pressure lots of big shoes to fill
you have read to help you right
he's not going to help me with
gabe you want to help i don't know man
you're spider-man 3 fan
[Music]
[Music]
it looks pretty good did the window just
fine too time to carve out the master
potato and ideas this is where our film
will go by the being about a thing look
at that work
great
do you think this will be able to
compete with the red uh maybe only in
terms of uh style like the red's all
black with like cool skulls and this is
all like yellow with like cool
smells
cool
you think this is just an ordinary
potato think again
potato camera
all right so i finished hollowing out
the potato this fits in there nice and
snug and that's going to project an
image hopefully onto our film all right
so the potato construction is done we're
ready to throw the film chamber in there
take our pictures but i want to make
sure this lens is working we're going to
put this on a real camera we're going to
get a sense of exposure what setting
should we be at because we need to have
the stop down a fair amount what we're
sure we can do is we can control the
aperture on this lens and the tighter
the aperture the more things are in
focus so we can't see what we're
shooting you can only point the potato
at it and hope it comes out beautifully
so we're going to set the aperture to
around an f11 and then we know our film
is 100 iso so we put this lens on real
camera and we stop it down to f11 and we
set the camera's iso to 100 then we
should get a reading for the shutter
speed how long we need to take our lens
cap off and then put it back on to take
our picture here at one fourth of a
second it's a perfect exposure in here
it's a potato camera
oh i think this is going to work i think
we're ready to load some film in this
son
look at my new camera does it work
uh i think it does
so we'll have the lens cap on it's time
to take a picture and just take it off
and put it back on but how are you going
to keep it from shaking
it might but then it's gonna be blurry
it might be already but we're gonna use
a tripod
i think having a photo existed
is more of a priority than whether or
not it's blurry like man everybody's
just always doubting my potato camera
it's never gonna work ever you can't
make a potato camera you know what you
should give up now
potatoes are meant for one thing only
eating this is gonna get popular and
there's gonna be another famine isn't
there yeah
so we have one more big challenge ahead
of us to get this to work the thing is
if any light hits the undeveloped film
it ruins it straight up so we need to be
in a pitch black room when we cut the
film into nine inch trips we need to
stay in that pitch black room when we
load it into here and make sure it's
loaded correctly and get it all sealed
up we can't let any light leak into this
potato if that happens the film is
ruined traditionally in dark rooms they
have a light with a red of a certain
wavelength that doesn't expose the film
i thought a phillips hue light might
work but we decided not to risk it we're
gonna go extra safe we're gonna use an
infrared camera and be in pitch
blackness for this to work
okay just gotta memorize everything is
i'm gonna place everything beforehand
here we go
i can't see anything there's some
glow-in-the-dark things on the ceiling
apparently dude
should we turn on the light to take
these down no this is way better here
where's the scissors
you fill out the fluorescent light
[ __ ] here that's not good to breathe
i recently retired from corridor digital
and moved to fiji because this episode
is brought to you by squarespace and
squarespace is so easy to use that i
just quit and move to a far away island
it's so easy i make websites for
everybody here in fiji squarespace has
beautiful award-winning templates
meaning you don't need to know anything
about code in order to use their website
do you see the do you see those surfers
down there
hey guys yeah they're having a great
time because you know why the
squarespace is flexible for any kind of
website meaning that if you're a surfer
a frank over there the luau cook hey i
see you over there you crazy animal
don't think you're going anywhere
squarespace has an all-in-one platform
meaning there's nothing to install
patcher upgrade ever ah
wow do you feel that ocean breeze
that's what they're 24 7 award-winning
customer service feels like so great
remember you can get 10 off your first
purchase by going to squarespace.com
forward slash corridor crew right now
you'll thank me later cannonball
oh
now make sure we don't overexpose the
film this is how it's supposed to go
down man huh but spencer died in a train
accident 20 years ago
i kill a slice
[Music]
all right everything's sealed okay i'm
gonna turn on the light go for it
let's do it yep don't move
okay that's it
now i did one i need to advance the film
so i need to open this up again and do
that
no moving three two one
that's it
all right all right guys
if we get any image if you can even make
out a human i'll be happy that'll be a
success if there's
if there's any actual
even if it's blurry even though we've
been really careful there's probably a
30 chance we're actually gonna get
something 30 chance that something will
actually get anything yeah
oh we got some stuff these black squares
are the exposures oh man there's a ghost
in them you can see people
there's like these ghostly people
something blurry's happening right there
it totally works it totally works
what holy [ __ ]
when they developed it they didn't think
it worked look at there's a slenderman
it's just a slenderman camera
oh look at that slendy oh that's a real
good slendy right there we have all the
negatives here so now we need to do is
scan them in and inverse the colors so
you can see what the images look like
cover it up to the right
it's probably super blurry and out of
focus probably oh my god that totally
worked there's images
there's something there's actually
people oh that's pretty cool
it literally is potato quality
i'm not sure who that was i think that's
you yeah i think this is gabe i believe
gabe and peter i think yeah yeah i think
there might have been double imprints
like here this photo might have been one
of these when it's laying on top of it
something we did like double expose
which is kind of cool actually it's one
of our best photos yeah it's true
whatever you can actually see the logo
the indigo prince logo on gabe's shirt
yeah
that's jake and christian
their arms
freaking boss mode dude definitely out
of focus
yeah oh wow yeah
i believe that's i can see it you're
right yeah i can see it i can see it
here well you can see the light switch
you can see the door see the conduit box
this one's a really spooky one
that's like the oak zone that looks like
album art for a dark ambient
so that's you clint and that's me i
believe there it is oh yeah oh yeah yeah
he sees you is he a shirt oh who's this
oh who's this someone with a
gun no it's with an axe they're holding
it towards the camera that's christian
yeah doing his classic christian pose
that one worked worked really well it's
in focus actually this makes sense oh my
god his socks are in focus wow that
works great
i feel like foggy if you stand back and
blur your eyes you can see his camo
shorts yep you can see white shoes his
white socks and his arms crossed this
yeah that looks really good oh my god oh
wow that was super in focus freaking
slender man over here dude hey man who's
this that's definitely me mainly just
because i remember specifically doing
that pose is that jake yep that's jake
it's definitely jake it's definitely
jake these ones are actually these ones
are almost perfect to be honest with you
exposure wise like kind of about as good
as it gets
so our potato camera does exactly what
we thought it would do which is take
crappy but still visible pictures kind
of worked like we got these weird
ghostly figures which is actually
exactly what i was hoping for